I don't know if you've seen this guy Hamid Karzai, the President of Afghanistan, on TV, heard him on the radio, but that is one charming man.
不知道你是否在电视上见过阿富汗总统哈米德·卡尔扎伊，或者在广播里听过他的声音，但他确实是一位很有魅力的人。
A year ago this week, in January 2002-- not long after the Taliban were driven from power in Afghanistan-- he came to the United States, partly to be on hand for the State of the Union address last year. And while he was here, he spoke with an audience that was mostly Afghan-Americans at Georgetown University. And he said to them, in Pashto and then in English, come back. Come back to Afghanistan. He directed this especially to the young people.
那是2002年1月，塔利班被赶出阿富汗政权后不久。当时他来到美国，部分原因是为了出席去年的国情咨文演讲。在美期间，他在乔治城大学对一群主要是阿富汗裔美国人的听众发表了讲话。他用普什图语，然后又用英语对他们说，回来吧，回到阿富汗来。他特别向年轻人发出了这个呼吁。
Work hard. Learn well. Study well, and make money. Bring it to Afghanistan.
努力工作，学好知识，好好学习，挣钱。把钱带回阿富汗。
He grinned at the audience. Then read from this card that had been handed to him with a question on it.
他向听众咧嘴一笑，然后读了一张递给他的写着问题的卡片。
OK, specifically, how would you suggest the younger generation of Afghans living in US-- OK. Specifically, your areas in which you have studied. Those of you who have gone through university and have acquired degrees in various fields-- medicine, engineering, computers, management, banking, business administration, all that. These are the areas-- statistics, by the way. We need that very much. Accounting, auditing. So do come.
好的，具体来说，你建议居住在美国的阿富汗年轻一代怎么做——好的。具体来说，在你们学习的领域。你们中那些已经读完大学并获得了不同领域学位的人——医学、工程学、计算机、管理学、银行学、工商管理等等。这些都是需要的领域——顺便提一下，还有统计学，我们非常需要这个。会计、审计。所以，一定要回来。
In addition to that, if somebody wants to be the president, she or he is also welcome. So all are welcome.
除此之外，如果有人想当总统，他也同样受欢迎。所以大家都受欢迎。
Afghanistan had been at work for 22 years. There were the Soviets, then the ten-year fight to expel them. Then the war between the Afghans. Then the Taliban took over.
阿富汗经历了22年的战乱。先是苏联人，然后是长达十年的驱逐他们的战争。接着是阿富汗人之间的内战，然后是塔利班夺取政权。
As a result, an entire generation of Afghans has grown up in the United States. Teenagers today who are much more American than they are Afghan. Many of them have never seen their country.
结果是，整整一代阿富汗人在美国长大。今天的青少年比起阿富汗人，更像美国人。他们中许多人从未见过自己的国家。
And it's possible that the very first teenager to take Hamid Karzai's invitation to heart and return to Afghanistan was a 17-year-old from Northern California named Hyder Akbar. And, as luck would have it, before he went, he met a radio producer named Susan Burton, and she urged him to take a tape recorder along on the trip.
很有可能，第一个把哈米德·卡尔扎伊的邀请铭记在心并回到阿富汗的少年，是来自北加州的一位17岁少年，名叫海德·阿克巴尔。碰巧的是，在他出发前，他遇到了一位名叫苏珊·伯顿的广播制作人，她极力劝说他带上录音机去旅行。
Well, today we feel lucky to bring you the recordings that he made. As you'll hear, Hyder's father had moved back to Afghanistan-- months before Hyder went-- to work for Hamid Karzai in the new government of the country. And because of his father's position, which was pretty high up in the government, Hyder gets an insider's look at everything going on in the country. It is a very unusual glimpse at a country that most of us still do not really have much sense of.
今天，我们很荣幸能为您播放他所录制的内容。正如你即将听到的，海德的父亲在海德出发前几个月就已经搬回了阿富汗，为哈米德·卡尔扎伊的新政府工作。由于他父亲在政府中职位相当高，海德得以从内部视角观察国家正在发生的一切。这让我们得以一窥我们大多数人其实并不太了解的一个国家。
Of course, this is This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
当然，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
For most of our show today, you're going to be hearing the recordings that Hyder made himself. But to give you a sense of who Hyder was before he went on his trip to Afghanistan, Susan Burton begins Hyder's story before the trip at his home in Concord, California.
今天节目的大部分时间，你们将听到海德亲自录制的录音。但为了让你们了解海德在去阿富汗之前是个什么样的人，苏珊·伯顿将从海德在加州康科德的家中，在他出发前开始讲述他的故事。
When Hyder goes to Barnes and Noble, the first thing he does with any new book they have in about Afghanistan is turn to the index and look up Kabul Radio. It's pretty much always in there, because on the night in 1979 when the Soviets took Kabul, they stormed two places. One was the palace and the other was Kabul Radio. Kabul Radio was headed by Hyder's dad.
当海德去巴诺书店时，他看到任何关于阿富汗的新书，做的第一件事就是翻到索引查找“喀布尔电台”。它几乎总是出现在里面，因为1979年苏联占领喀布尔的那天晚上，他们袭击了两个地方。一个是宫殿，另一个就是喀布尔电台。喀布尔电台的负责人就是海德的父亲。
During the years of the resistance, Hyder's dad had two close friends. One was Hamid Karzai, now the President of Afghanistan, and the other was a legendary commander named Abdul Haq. After he looks up Kabul Radio, the next thing Hyder looks up in any book is always Abdul Haq. In his favorite book, Soldiers of God by Robert D. Kaplan, there's an entire chapter, chapter five, completely and totally devoted to Abdul Haq. One time Hyder told his mother what Kaplan said about Abdul Haq's headquarters in Peshawar.
在抵抗运动的那些年里，海德的父亲有两位密友。一位是现在的阿富汗总统哈米德·卡尔扎伊，另一位是一位传奇指挥官，名叫阿卜杜勒·哈克。查找完喀布尔电台后，海德在任何书中查找的下一件事总是阿卜杜勒·哈克。在他最喜欢的书，罗伯特·D·卡普兰所著的《上帝的士兵》中，有一整章，第五章，完全致力于描写阿卜杜勒·哈克。有一次，海德告诉他母亲卡普兰关于阿卜杜勒·哈克在白沙瓦总部时的描述。
And then he describes how he went into his office, and how he was always busy, and he had one hand on the phone, another one looking at some maps. And you always felt like you were wasting time when you were [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. And my mom was like, wait. He wasn't that busy. He was at our house every single day.
他描述了他走进办公室的情景，他总是很忙，一只手拿着电话，另一只手看着地图。你总是觉得你在浪费时间，当你在[听不清]的时候。我妈说，等等，他没那么忙，他每天都在我们家。
Hyder's dad worked with the resistance. For years, Hyder didn't see his dad and didn't know his hero, Abdul Haq. When Abdul Haq suddenly showed up at the family's house in California a couple weeks before September 11, Hyder was speechless. That day, Abdul Haq told Hyder's dad that he was scheming to topple the Taliban. Not long after September 11, he got in touch again. He was going in. He was ready.
海德的父亲曾与抵抗组织合作。多年来，海德没有见过父亲，也不认识他的英雄阿卜杜勒·哈克。当阿卜杜勒·哈克在9月11日的前几周突然出现在他们加州的家时，海德惊呆了。那天，阿卜杜勒·哈克告诉海德的父亲，他正计划推翻塔利班。9月11日后不久，他又联系了。他要进去了。他准备好了。
Days after Abdul Haq snuck into Afghanistan, Hyder came home from school and found his mother crying in her bedroom. Abdul Haq had been captured and killed by the Taliban, shot with dozens of bullets, then hung from a tree. Hyder wrote about the execution in his current events journal at school the next day, and a teacher wrote a check mark, and then, in red ballpoint pen, "Sorry."
阿卜杜勒·哈克潜入阿富汗几天后，海德放学回家，发现母亲在卧室里哭泣。阿卜杜勒·哈克被塔利班抓获并杀害，身上中了几十枪，然后被吊在树上。第二天，海德在学校的时事日志中写下了这次处决，老师打了一个勾，然后用红色圆珠笔写了“对不起”。
Just weeks after Abdul Haq's death, the Taliban were defeated by the American forces. The next month, Hyder's dad had a long talk with his old friend Hamid Karzai, sold his business, and left for Afghanistan.
阿卜杜勒·哈克死后仅仅几周，塔利班就被美军击败了。下个月，海德的父亲与老友哈米德·卡尔扎伊进行了一次长谈，卖掉了生意，动身前往阿富汗。
OK. This is my room. To the right is the TV, and I have a couple of video games and stuff like that.
好了。这是我的房间。右边是电视，我有几个电子游戏之类的东西。
When I first meet Hyder, he shows me around his house. We sit down in the living room and look at family photos, like a snapshot of Hamid Karzai at Disneyland maybe 20 years ago, baby-faced, standing next to Goofy.
我第一次见到海德时，他带我参观了他的房子。我们坐在客厅里看家庭照片，比如大约20年前哈米德·卡尔扎伊在迪士尼乐园的一张快照，长着一张娃娃脸，站在高飞旁边。
Well, this is an issue, September 1968, it's a National Geographic issue.
好吧，这是一期杂志，1968年9月的《国家地理》。
Hyder opens the old magazine, which he bid for off of Ebay, and shows me a favorite picture of Afghanistan.
海德打开了那本他从eBay上竞拍来的旧杂志，给我看一张他最喜欢的阿富汗照片。
Actually, I really, really, really like this picture. This is more of the countryside of Afghanistan. And it's green, green grass and trees, and then there's just like blue, blue water flowing through. Yeah. There's a shepherd here, and then there's a cow but I'm sure. That house looks pretty neat, too. In the middle of the river, there's a rock, and there's a house built on top of it. I don't know how he gets back to the land, But I think he would probably goes through  these rocks or something.
其实，我真的、真的、非常喜欢这张照片。这是阿富汗的乡村风景。那里有绿油油的草地和树木，还有流淌的湛蓝的河水。是的，这里有一个牧羊人，还有一头牛。那栋房子看起来也很不错。河中间有一块石头，上面盖了一栋房子。我不知道他怎么回到岸上，但我认为他可能会穿过这些岩石之类的。
We look at the picture for so long that it starts to seem to me almost like a fairytale picture you can enter inside. Like when the movie camera goes in for a closeup on a color plate in a storybook, and then all of a sudden, the wagons are rolling and the animals' tails are swishing in Dolby stereo, and the action is actually happening right there.
我们盯着这张照片看了很久，以至于它开始让我觉得就像一张可以走进的神话照片。就像电影摄影机聚焦在故事书的彩色插图上一样，突然间，马车行驶起来，动物的尾巴在杜比立体声中摇摆，动作就在那里真实发生。
Before Hyder's dad left for Afghanistan, he owned a hip hop clothes store in Oakland. A few months ago, he was selling FUBU pants to teenagers. Now he spends his days with the people running Afghanistan.
在海德的父亲离开阿富汗之前，他在奥克兰拥有一家嘻哈服装店。几个月前，他还把FUBU裤子卖给青少年。现在，他每天都和经营阿富汗的人在一起。
Hyder shows me a picture taken just a couple weeks before of his dad sitting near Karzai at a medieval-looking dining table in the palace in Kabul at a meeting about peacekeeping troops.
海德给我看了一张几天前拍的照片，照片里他父亲坐在喀布尔宫殿一张看起来很中世纪的餐桌旁，在参加关于维和部队的会议，靠近卡尔扎伊。
When I see this, I'm really, really happy for him. Because it's kind of like his dream. I could tell how bored and how frustrated he was living here, and having to just be at the store and just live everyday life. I remember for a couple years, my mom was telling him, don't even interact with people. I think it's pretty much because he had lost hope. It was weird.
当我看到这个时，我真的为他感到非常非常高兴。因为这对他来说就像是一个梦想。我能看出他住在这里是多么无聊和沮丧，不得不只是待在店里过着日常生活。我记得有几年，我妈妈一直在告诉他，不要和人交往。我想这大概是因为他失去了希望。那很奇怪。
I mean, a lot of people have been effected by September 11, but like, our family's literally turned upside down. Even me. My whole plan of my life has changed.
我是说，很多人受到了9月11日的影响，但像我们家真的是天翻地覆。甚至连我。我整个人生计划都改变了。
Before September 11, Hyder thought he'd study business, maybe become a mortgage broker, like his older brother. But after, Hyder felt like he had found his mission in life. He would do something big to help Afghanistan rebuild, like become a politician or an engineer.
9月11日之前，海德想学商科，也许像他哥哥那样成为一名抵押贷款经纪人。但在那之后，海德觉得他找到了人生的使命。他要做大事来帮助阿富汗重建，比如成为一名政治家或工程师。
The one problem was, all of his dreams took place in a country to which he'd never been. So he convinced his dad to let him join up with him in Afghanistan for the summer.
唯一的问题是，他所有的梦想都在一个他从未去过的国家。所以他说服了他父亲，让他今年夏天去阿富汗加入他。
Like, I read a lot about it, and I learn a lot. By now I know a lot about it. But I've never visited it. So that's another reason I really want to go. Because it's easy to talk, but then to actually do it is much harder, you know? That's what my father was telling me, too. Right now it's easy to talk about going back, but once you have to, like, take a glass of water, cold water, and put it over your head, and that's how you take the shower, and on mountains, and you have like a biscuit in your hand, it's not as easy.
就像，我读了很多关于它的书，也学到了很多。到现在我知道了很多。但我从未去过。所以这是我非常想去的另一个原因。因为说起来容易，但真正去做要困难得多，你知道吗？这也是我父亲告诉我的。现在谈论回去很容易，但一旦你不得不，比如，拿一杯水，冷水，倒在头上，这就是洗澡的方式，而且是在山上，手里还要拿着一块饼干，这并不容易。
When your dad said that to you, was that kind of sobering?
当你父亲对你说这些时，那让你感到冷静了吗？
No, it actually made me more hard-headed, and even want to go back even more, you know? Just to prove it, and just to get the doubts out of my head. It's almost like a test, you know? I want to pass it. It's almost like a test on how much I can take.
不，它实际上让我变得更加固执，甚至更想回去，你知道吗？只是为了证明这一点，并把脑子里的怀疑消除掉。这几乎像是一场考试，你知道吗？我想通过它。这几乎像是在测试我能承受多少。
OK, on the test, or quiz, I should say--
好的，在考试，或者说小测验上——
There are a lot of Afghan kids at Hyder's high school, but he tries not to talk too much about his trip with them, or with anyone. The whole thing means so much to him that it's difficult to explain.
海德的高中里有很多阿富汗孩子，但他尽量不和他们，或者任何人谈论他的旅行。整件事对他意义重大，以至于很难解释。
On the day I visit his English class, the teacher shows the movie version of Frankenstein , and after, everyone's supposed to list five differences from the book. But instead, everyone's just talking. And a girl eating saltines one by one out of a package on her desk asks Hyder how come he's going, and if he's ever coming back.
我访问他英语课的那天，老师放映了电影版的《科学怪人》，之后大家被要求列出电影与原著的五个不同点。但相反，大家都在聊天。一个坐在桌子边吃着盐饼干的女孩问海德为什么要去，以及他是否还会回来。
How come you're going back? [INAUDIBLE]
你为什么要回去？[听不清]
Yeah, I'm coming back. But I don't know. It's a pretty long answer, so I really can't summarize it in--
是的，我会回来的。但我不知道。这是一个很长的答案，所以我真的不能总结成——
Hyder's friend Alex jumps in.
海德的朋友亚历克斯插话道。
He's really deep with his roots. Let's just say that. He's going to get his education here, and then move back to Afghanistan and help rebuild it.
他有着很深的根源。我们就这么说吧。他打算在这里接受教育，然后搬回阿富汗帮助重建。
Really? Wow! That's cool. That's a pretty good summary.
真的吗？哇！那太酷了。那是个很不错的总结。
Oh, I'm his manager.
噢，我是他的经纪人。
Alex is not Afghan, but everyone calls him "Halfghan," because he can recite his cell phone number in Dari.
亚历克斯不是阿富汗人，但大家都叫他“半个阿富汗人”，因为他可以用达里语背出自己的手机号码。
A lot of these kids saw a picture Hyder's father sent of Hamid Karzai sitting at his desk in the palace holding a satellite phone,. And today they joke with Hyder about the various devices he might use to keep in touch with them over the summer.
这些孩子中很多都看过海德父亲寄来的一张照片，照片里哈米德·卡尔扎伊坐在宫殿的桌子旁，拿着一部卫星电话。今天，他们和海德开玩笑，讨论他夏天可能会用来和他们保持联系的各种设备。
Oh, you should get a two-way from here to Afghanistan.
噢，你应该从这儿带个对讲机去阿富汗。
Why don't you bring a laptop? Wireless internet!
你为什么不带台笔记本电脑？无线网络！
Yeah. You'll be like, hey, Hyder, how's Afghanistan.
是啊。到时候你就会说，嘿，海德，阿富汗怎么样。
"I met the greatest girl--"
“我遇到了最棒的女孩——”
"I haven't seen her face yet, but."
“虽然我还没见过她的脸。”
"I haven't seen her face yet," the boy says.
“我还没见过她的脸，”那个男孩说。
Hyder loves his friends, but says it's weird, because they're interested in all the regular stuff. Girls, cars, different kinds of sneakers. Where Hyder wishes that he could zoom ahead to being a grown up and moving back to Afghanistan.
海德爱他的朋友们，但他说这很奇怪，因为他们对所有普通的事情感兴趣。女孩、汽车、不同种类的运动鞋。而海德希望自己能快进到成年并搬回阿富汗。
That's another thing. Unlike most of his friends and cousins, he doesn't feel American.
这是另一件事。与他的大多数朋友和表兄弟不同，他并不觉得自己是美国人。
I do feel like somewhat of an outsider here. It's really weird. I've never been in my own country. I think that's one of the reasons I really want to go now, is just to see. And I almost feel I have like an insecurity.
我确实在这里感到某种局外人。这真的很奇怪。我从来没有在自己的国家待过。我认为这就是我现在真的很想去的其中一个原因，就是去看看。我几乎觉得我有一种不安全感。
There's so much more that could have happened to me, you know? If I wasn't so fortunate, I could have easily been growing up there right now. Growing up in a generation that literally doesn't know anything but war. I think anything could happen to me and I would still almost always not try to complain about it, because of what Afghans have been through, especially in Afghanistan.
如果我没有那么幸运，本来还会有很多事情发生在我身上，你知道吗？如果不是那么幸运，我很容易现在就会在那里长大。在这一代人中长大，他们真的除了战争什么都不知道。我想无论发生什么事情，我都几乎总是不会试图抱怨，因为阿富汗人所经历的一切，尤其是在阿富汗。
Hyder's been toughening up for this trip. Before leaving for Afghanistan, his dad made a deal with him. If he wanted him to buy him a ticket, he had to lose weight. Hyder started running on a treadmill in his garage wearing a sweatshirt, plus another shirt, plus a garbage bag, to help him sweat more. In two months, he's lost 65 pounds.
海德一直在为这次旅行锻炼身体。在去阿富汗之前，他父亲和他达成了一笔交易。如果想让他买票，就得减肥。海德开始在车库里穿着运动衫，外面再加一件衣服，再加上一个垃圾袋，在跑步机上跑步以帮助出汗。两个月里，他瘦了65磅。
And there's another detail to take care of.
还有另一个细节要处理。
The other day, my mom told me to make sure you get your shots before going to Afghanistan. And I actually don't want to take them. Because I don't know, it kind of adds on more to the foreigner, an American, going to Afghanistan. It might seem silly or childish or too much testosterone or whatever, but I just don't want to go in and get shots to make sure I don't get sick or malaria or anything. Because my father never had to. I'm kind of like, it's my own country. I'm just going to go in there. I don't want them to think of me as a foreigner.
前几天，我妈告诉我一定要在去阿富汗之前打预防针。而我其实不想去打。因为我不知道，这似乎更增加了那种外国人，一个美国人，去阿富汗的感觉。这可能听起来很傻或很幼稚，或者是荷尔蒙过剩什么的，但我就是不想进去打针来确保自己不生病或疟疾什么的。因为我父亲从来不用打。我有点觉得，这是我自己的国家。我只是要进去。我不想让他们把我当作外国人。
Hyder's trip is just six weeks away. He's hoping that instead of flying straight to Kabul, he can arrange to travel over the Khyber pass. That's the right way to do it, he says. That's the way everyone's done it. The Mongols, the British conquerors, the mujahideen. He's planning what to pack-- traditional Afghan clothes, his books about Afghanistan, and batteries so that he can listen to his U2 CDs. He picks up the remote control for his stereo.
海德的行程还有六周。他希望不要直接飞往喀布尔，而是能安排通过开伯尔山口。他说，那是正确的做法。那是每个人都走过的路。蒙古人、英国征服者、圣战者。他正在计划打包什么——传统的阿富汗服装、关于阿富汗的书籍，以及电池，这样他就能听他的U2乐队CD。他拿起了立体声系统的遥控器。
You know, that's a pretty famous U2 song.  It's the one they sing on top of the roof, "Where the Streets Have No Name." You know what I'm talking about? Yeah. It's hard to explain. I think it's in the CD player right now, so one sec. Yeah. And it's kind of like, when I picture that place, "Where the Streets Have No Name," I picture something like Afghanistan, you know? And I think it's a song, it's pretty much tired about how set and systematic the world is. Yeah. Like, "I want to run, I want to hide, I want to tear down the walls that hold me inside." So it's kind of like at the point where I am right now. Just, I feel really-- held down.
你知道，那是一首非常著名的U2歌曲。那是他们在屋顶唱的那首歌，“Where the Streets Have No Name”。你知道我说的是哪一首吗？是的。很难解释。我想它现在就在CD机里，等一下。是的。这有点像，当我想象那个地方时，“Where the Streets Have No Name”，我想象的是像阿富汗那样的地方，你知道吗？我认为这是一首歌，它几乎是对世界是多么刻板和系统化感到厌倦。是的。就像，“我想要奔跑，我想要躲藏，我想要推倒禁锢我的围墙。”所以这有点像我目前所处的阶段。只是，我感觉真的——被压制住了。
[MUSIC - "WHERE THE STREETS HAVE NO NAME" BY U2]
[音乐 - U2的《WHERE THE STREETS HAVE NO NAME》]
Before I leave, I show Hyder how to work the tape recorder he'll be taking to Afghanistan.
在我离开之前，我教海德如何操作他将带去阿富汗的录音机。
Hello, hello. It's 8:40 in the morning, Monday, May 27. And I'm leaving today. This is my last day here.
你好，你好。现在是5月27日星期一早上8:40。我今天就要走了。这是我在这里的最后一天。
I was listening to the radio the other day, and they had a funny commercial. They're promoting some contest to go to a trip anywhere. and they were naming all these countries. Italy, France. And then they're like, Afghanistan. And then they started like, ha, they make like this funny music. And they're like, OK. Well, maybe not Afghanistan. And it just hit me as weird since I'm going there today. I'm going today.
前几天我在听广播，他们有个有趣的广告。他们正在宣传某个比赛，去任何地方旅行。他们列举了所有这些国家。意大利、法国。然后他们说，阿富汗。然后他们开始，哈哈，他们制造这种有趣的音乐。然后他们说，好吧。嗯，可能不是阿富汗。这对我来说很奇怪，因为我今天要去那里。我今天就要去了。
I just got done speaking to my dad about 15 minutes ago, and he confirmed that somebody's going to come and pick me up in Peshawar. I'll probably spend the night at a relative's house over there. And from there I'm going to drive to Kabul, which is like a six hour drive from Peshawar. Then he told me to shave my goatee. So I'll go ahead and shave that.
我15分钟前刚和我爸谈过，他确认会有人来白沙瓦接我。我可能会在那里的亲戚家过夜。从那里我将开车去喀布尔，这离白沙瓦大约有六小时车程。然后他让我把山羊胡剃了。所以我这就去把它剃了。
That's about it. I'm just really, really excited. I just feel like going, "ahhhh!" I'm just really, really, really, really, really, really, really excited. Signing off from San Francisco. Next recording you'll hear will probably be from Peshawar. Goodbye.
就这些了。我真的、真的非常兴奋。我感觉想要大喊，“啊！”我真的、真的、真的、真的、真的、真的、真的非常兴奋。从旧金山签字离开。你听到的下一段录音可能是在白沙瓦录的。再见。
Hello, hello? I'm actually on my way to Torkham right now, the border station between Afghanistan and Pakistan. I arrived at the house in Peshawar. I knew I had arrived when I saw an AK-47 in the living room, just lying up against the cabinet. Fully loaded and ready to go.
喂，喂？我现在正在去托克罕的路上，那是阿富汗和巴基斯坦之间的边境站。我到达了白沙瓦的房子。当我看到客厅里靠着橱柜的一把AK-47时，我就知道我到了。装满弹药，准备就绪。
I got stopped by police and got checked and everything. Because they saw the microphone. But I turned it on really quick.
我被警察拦下，进行了检查之类的。因为他们看到了麦克风。但我很快就把它打开了。
We're at the Kyber Pass right now, and it's pretty incredible. There's two mountains down there. It's right between mountain ridges. I don't want to attract unwanted attention, but I am passing through the Khyber Pass right now. This is the Khyber Pass.
我们现在在开伯尔山口，真是太不可思议了。下面有两座山。它就在山脊之间。我不想引起不必要的注意，但我现在正穿过开伯尔山口。这就是开伯尔山口。
So I was going through the Khyber Pass. And we reached Torkham, finally. I didn't really have that sense of wow, this is my country, you know? I'm finally in Afganistan. None of that kiss the ground stuff. You know, I just saw a lot of poor kids running around, a lot of burkas, beards. I felt like a total outsider.
所以我穿过了开伯尔山口。我们终于到达了托克罕。我并没有那种“哇，这是我的国家”的感觉，你知道吗？我终于在阿富汗了。没有那种吻土地之类的东西。你知道，我只是看到很多贫穷的孩子跑来跑去，很多穿罩袍的，留胡子的。我感觉自己完全是个局外人。
My dad kept on telling me, the road to Kabul is horrible. It's really bad. It's really bad. It's really been destroyed.
我爸一直告诉我，去喀布尔的路太可怕了。真的很糟。真的很糟。它确实被摧毁了。
So I'm thinking, fine. A bad road. Potholes here and there. A lot. Probably have to slow down, go around them, et cetera.
所以我心想，好吧。一条糟糕的路。到处都是坑坑洼洼。很多。可能必须减速，绕过它们等等。
No. I mean, he said road. This is the key was there. So I was thinking there would be a road there. What he should have said is from Jalalabad to Kabul, there's no road. I think my head probably hit the top of the car about like 30 times through the whole ride. And towards the end of the trip, I was starting to get motion sickness, and I was feeling like I was going to throw up, and I was getting really sick and dizzy. This whole place is so barren and so--
不。我是说，他说路。这就是关键所在。所以我以为那里会有路。他应该说的是从贾拉拉巴德到喀布尔，根本没有路。我想我的头在整个行程中可能撞到车顶大约30次。而在行程快结束时，我开始晕车，感觉要吐了，而且感到非常恶心和头晕。整个地方太贫瘠，太——
To tell you the truth, I kind of had regret for what I had done. I was like, wow. You know, maybe I wasn't ready for this.
老实说，我对我所做的事情有点后悔。我当时想，哇。你知道，也许我还没准备好面对这一切。
I'm at the doorway of the Kabul Hotel right now. We're actually invited somewhere for lunch. We're going to go there right now.
我现在在喀布尔酒店的门口。我们其实被邀请去吃午饭。我们现在就要去了。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
That's my dad. All right.
那是我爸。好的。
The hotel, Kabul Hotel. Let me describe the hotel to you. Me and my dad, we're in same room. It's a pretty small room. There's two beds, a little, like, area where you can sit, balcony where probably like three people could stand.
酒店，喀布尔酒店。让我描述一下这个酒店。我和我爸住同一个房间。这是一个相当小的房间。有两张床，一个小小的可以坐的地方，阳台大概能站三个人。
There's actually a huge place where a missile had hit Kabul Hotel, and it's still like that, you know? There's like this huge hole, all, like, four stories, on one side. And this is probably one of the nicest hotels here.
实际上有一个巨大的地方，是一枚导弹击中了喀布尔酒店，现在还是那样，你知道吗？有一处巨大的洞，贯穿了所有四层楼，在一侧。这大概是这里最好的酒店之一。
Hello, hello? I think it's my fourth day in Kabul. Anyway, I was just coming out of the bathroom after I cleaned myself for evening prayers, and I just heard a couple of rockets outside. I ran to the balcony real quick just to see what was going on. And everybody-- except for like a few people who jumped up, just trying to see where it was coming from-- the rest of the city was functioning pretty normal. It was pretty weird.
喂，喂？我想这是我在喀布尔的第四天。总之，我刚在清理完晚祷后走出浴室，就听到外面有几声火箭弹。我立刻跑到阳台看看到底发生了什么。每个人——除了几个跳起来试图看它来自哪里的人——城市的其余部分都在正常运转。那真奇怪。
Let me ask my dad if he saw that too, that the whole city was pretty normal. My dad, I think, listened to the news.
让我问问我爸他是否也看到了，整个城市都很正常。我爸，我想，听了新闻。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]?
[说普什图语]？
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
Yeah, my dad said the same thing. He said that everybody's just going about their own business. That's basically what he just said in Pashto. I've seen plenty of rockets here in Kabul.
是的，我爸也说了同样的话。他说每个人都在忙自己的事。这基本上就是他刚才用普什图语说的。我在喀布尔见过很多火箭弹。
I'm going to go do my evening prayers. Go downstairs.
我要去做晚祷了。下楼去。
Today was a really interesting day. I went to the palace today, and there was this incredible, like-- it was almost like going through a movie. Like this old, the gates and how they open, and the huge locks. It almost looked like you're visiting someplace in Disneyland or Universal Studios. But it was the real thing.
今天真是非常有意思的一天。我今天去了宫殿，真是不可思议——那简直就像是走进了一部电影。那些古老的、大门以及它们是如何打开的，还有巨大的锁。看起来几乎像是你正在去迪士尼乐园或环球影城参观。但那是真实的东西。
All of a sudden Karzai comes out, sees my dad, and he says hello. And my dad introduces me to him, he's like, this is my son. I got kind of nervous, actually. You know? It's hard not to be, meeting him. You know, that queasy feeling in your stomach. Felt my, you know, like, heart rate go up.
突然卡尔扎伊出来，看见我爸，他说你好。我爸把我介绍给他，他说，这是我儿子。我其实有点紧张。你知道吗？很难不紧张，见到他。你知道，那种胃里翻江倒海的感觉。感觉到我的，你知道，心跳加速。
And he walks so fast. He's so busy right now. It's just there's like four days to the [SPEAKING PASHTO]. He doesn't even walk. He practically runs.
他走得太快了。他现在太忙了。离[说普什图语]还有四天。他甚至不走路。他简直是在跑。
After that, somebody else was just entering the palace, and it was Rashid Dostum, probably the most infamous warlord. He's uh, pretty out there even by Afghan standards. I've heard stories about this guy rolling over people with tanks. Strapping people down to tanks and, like, crushing them. So it was weird to shake hands with that kind of a fellow.
在那之后，另一个人刚刚进入宫殿，那是拉希德·杜斯塔姆，大概是最臭名昭著的军阀。他，呃，即使以阿富汗的标准来看也是个狠角色。我听说过这个家伙用坦克碾压人们的故事。把人绑在坦克上，然后，像那样压死他们。所以和这样的人握手真是奇怪。
It's just really interesting, just being in the palace at a time like this, you know? This is the future of the country, right here. You have, like, infamous warlords walking this way and famous ministers walking that way. It's pretty exciting. I mean, it's like equivalent, I think, of Lollapalooza or something. Going backstage and getting to meet all of these rock stars going back and forth. It was kind of like that. As nerdy and dorky as that sounds, that's pretty much how it was like for me.
在这种时候身处宫殿，真是太有意思了，你知道吗？这国家的未来，就在这里。你让臭名昭著的军阀往这边走，著名的部长往那边走。这很令人兴奋。我是说，这相当于，我想，洛拉帕罗扎音乐节之类的。走到后台，见到所有这些来来回回的摇滚明星。就像那样。不管这听起来有多呆板或傻气，对我来说基本上就是这样。
So my dad has been appointed the governor of Kunar, but he really can't go there yet. There's still some resistance. In the morning, there's usually a lot of people from Kunar that come over to see my dad. 5:30 in the morning, completely dark outside, 30 people from Kunar are already lined up at the door.
所以我爸被任命为库纳尔省省长，但他现在真的还不能去那里。仍然有一些抵抗。早晨，通常有很多来自库纳尔的人来见我爸。凌晨5:30，外面一片漆黑，30个来自库纳尔的人已经在门口排队了。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
One time they left and my dad, he sat down and he actually told me almost everything that's been going on. And there's a lot going on and there's so many-- Politics is really dirty. That's all I can say. There's so much going on. There's so much against my dad, so much for my dad, so much up to my dad. It's really a big deal, you know, to trust me with all that. He warned me, too. Like, in this documentary, or when talking to other people, not to say anything. I can't even tell my mom on the phone about it, because you know how phones are listened.
有一次他们离开后，我爸坐下来，他实际上告诉了我几乎所有正在发生的事情。有很多事情在发生，而且有很多——政治真的很肮脏。我只能说这么多。正在发生的事情太多了。反对我爸的太多，支持我爸的太多，需要我爸处理的也太多。这真是件大事，你知道吗，他居然信任我，把这一切告诉我。他也警告过我。就像，在这部纪录片里，或者当和别人交谈时，不要说任何话。我甚至不能在电话里告诉我妈，因为你知道电话是怎么被监听的。
And when he said that to me, it really made me feel like his son. I'm always there. Right by his side. And like, all these tribal elders he meets, all these people he talks to like the most intimate stuff, and I'm just standing with him every second, you know, like this major commander, North Americans, and everything. And it's really amazing, I mean, how much he trusts me with everything. I've got to be careful and not ruin it.
当他对我说这些时，这真的让我感觉自己是他的儿子。我一直在那里。就在他身边。而且像，所有这些他见到的部落长老，所有这些他谈话的人，比如最私密的事情，我每一秒都站在他旁边，你知道，就像这个主要的指挥官，北美之行，还有一切。这真是太神奇了，我是说，他信任我处理所有事情。我必须小心，不要搞砸了。
I'm traveling to Parwan right now. God, this road is horrible.
我现在正在去帕尔旺的路上。天哪，这条路真是太烂了。
Parwan was a really interesting place. It was a sort of this vacation place for Afghans living in Kabul when it got a little hot. There was actually a lot of people there. A lot of people there. It was really packed.
帕尔旺是一个很有意思的地方。当喀布尔天气有点热时，它成了阿富汗人的一种度假胜地。那里确实有很多人。那里有很多人。真是挤满了。
It's almost a sign of things getting back to normal again. Like, people being able to visit Parwan again. Because ever since the jihad and the resistance, it was a key area of fighting. And it's really interesting to see all these people coming back after so many years.
这几乎是一个事情正在恢复正常的迹象。比如，人们能够再次访问帕尔旺。因为自从圣战和抵抗运动以来，它一直是战斗的关键地区。看到所有这些人在多年之后回来，真的很令人兴奋。
[MUSIC WITH DRUMS]
[配鼓声的音乐]
The Taliban had banned music for six years. And I think it's only  been like five or six months since music has come back. So it's also really new.
塔利班曾禁乐六年。我想音乐回来才不过五六个月。所以这也很新。
And then at this one point, there was actually these men started dancing, and all these people gathered around and they were all watching and clapping. And all of a sudden, some chump with a Kalashnikov came over, and he stopped the drummers and he stopped the dancing. He was like, what are you doing, blah blah blah, not Islamic, et cetera. It wasn't even, you know, like girls and boys dancing, or anything like that. That would be unthinkable. It was just a guy dancing.
然后在这一个时刻，实际上这些人开始跳舞，所有这些人都围了过来，他们都在看，鼓掌。突然间，有个拿着卡拉什尼科夫步枪的白痴走过来，他停下了鼓手，停下了舞蹈。他就像，你们在做什么，blablabla，不符合伊斯兰教义等等。甚至都不是，你知道，像女孩和男孩跳舞之类的。那将是不可想象的。那只是一个男人在跳舞。
And then later on, all of a sudden I see this huge mob running. And a Sikh was in front, and they were like dragging him forward with a Kalashnikov. A Sikh-- you know who Sikh are. They're the ones with the turbans and the beard. My dad was like, what's going on? They're like, oh. We caught him drinking alcohol. And I don't know what they were going to do to him. But whatever it was, it kind of put a damper on the whole thing.
后来，突然我看到一群人跑过来。一个锡克教徒在前面，他们正用卡拉什尼科夫枪拖着他往前走。一个锡克教徒——你知道谁是锡克教徒吗。就是那些戴着头巾留着胡子的人。我爸问，发生什么事了？他们说，哦。我们抓到他喝酒精了。我不知道他们要对他做什么。但无论是什么，它确实给整件事蒙上了一层阴影。
I am in my hotel room. It's around 9:30 AM. And my uncle came in. He's bought dye for his beard. He's laughing right now. He knows a little bit of English, and he figured out I was talking about him.
我在酒店房间里。大约是早上9:30。我叔叔进来了。他给他的胡子买了染发剂。他现在在笑。他懂一点英语，他看出我是在谈论他。
He has this coloring device in his hand. "Prime Cream Hair Color With Conditioner, 45 Black." And there's this lady with like wavy hair and a smiling face. A couple of white hairs growing, so he's going to get young again.
他手里拿着这个上色装置。“Prime Cream Hair Color With Conditioner, 45 Black”。上面有个有着波浪长发和笑脸的女士。长了几根白头发，所以他要变年轻了。
And it's really funny, because he's this like big, macho commander. Probably the biggest commander in the Kunar Province area, which is a major fighting area. He's lost an eye, you know? Always walking around with an AK. He went to the bathroom to go and color his beard.
这真的很有趣，因为他是一个典型的、大男子主义的指挥官。大概是库纳尔省地区最大的指挥官，那是一个主要的战斗区。他失去了一只眼睛，你知道吗？总是随身带着AK枪。他去浴室去染他的胡子了。
Yesterday he was showing me all these parts in his body that metal just left, you know, his arms-- "touch this, touch this." And I was touching it, and there's metal there, and there's metal in his head, and forehead, and upper arm, and elbow-- just, you know, shrapnel and bullet wounds, et cetera.
昨天他给我看他身体上那些金属留下的部位，你知道，他的手臂——“摸摸这个，摸摸这个”。我就摸了，那里有金属，他的头上、额头、上臂、肘部也有金属——只是，你知道，弹片和枪伤等等。
He came out right now.  He's closing the lid or something. I think he's working on it.
他刚才出来了。他在盖盖子之类的。我想他正在处理它。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]?
[说普什图语]？
[SPEAKING PASHTO].
[说普什图语]。
He colors his beard.
他给胡子染上色。
Testing, one, two, three. Testing.
测试，一，二，三。测试。
I'm sitting in my hotel room outside on the balcony. It's about nine o'clock at night.
我坐在酒店房间外面的阳台上。大约晚上九点。
Today Haji Abdul Qadir, the vice president of Afghanistan, was assassinated. And he was Abdul Haq's brother, and Abdul Haq was my dad's best friend.
今天阿富汗副总统哈吉·阿卜杜勒·卡迪尔被暗杀了。他是阿卜杜勒·哈克的弟弟，而阿卜杜勒·哈克是我爸最好的朋友。
We were actually taken to see-- me and my dad-- my dad took me with him. He was taken to go see the body. They had put him in a coffin and everything, and it was a-- I don't know what you call the room. I mean, is it, like, the frozen-- I mean, kind of like the cold room where they keep bodies, I guess.
我们实际上被带去看了——我和我爸——我爸带我跟他一起去了。他被带去看尸体。他们把他放在棺材里等等，那是一个——我不知道你叫这个房间什么。我的意思是，它是，比如，冰冻——我想就是存放尸体的冷藏室。
And to be honest with you, I have never really seen a dead body like that. And my dad-- I mean, this is the first time I realized how going through a war must change you. Because he totally just jumped at the body, I mean, as if he was alive, and he just grabbed the towel that was on him, and you could see-- it almost like scratched his face. There were scratch marks on his face.
老实说，我从来没有真正见过那样的死尸。但我爸——我的意思是，这是我第一次意识到经历战争是如何改变一个人的。因为他完全就冲向了尸体，我的意思是，仿佛他还活着，他就抓住了盖在他身上的毛巾，你可以看到——它几乎像是抓破了他的脸。他的脸上满是抓痕。
My dad actually touched his face and was like, oh, I see. There's f here, and here. I mean, totally cool. And my dad asked if he was shot in the face. And they were like, no, he wasn't shot in the face. He was shot in the heart. And my dad was like, OK. He just casually unwrapped the towel a little more, and there was a bullet wound there. My dad touched that, too, and he was like oh, OK. And he said a little prayer and we left the room.
我爸实际上摸了他的脸，就像，哦，我知道了。这有f，这里也有。我的意思是，完全冷静。我爸问他是否脸部中弹。他们说，不，他不是脸部中弹。他是心脏中弹。我爸说，好吧。他只是随意地又拉开了一点毛巾，那里有一个弹孔。我爸也摸了那里，然后就像，哦，好吧。他做了个简短的祷告，我们就离开了房间。
It was happening way too quick to sink in. I think I'll age about five years in these three months.
这一切发生得太快，让人无法消化。我想我在三个月内会老五岁。
So I was up pretty late this morning. 7:30, 8 o'clock. I had a hard time sleeping last night again. Knowing, you know, my dad could be assassinated just like Haji Qadir.
所以我今天早上起得挺晚的。七点半，八点。昨晚我又很难入睡。我知道，你知道，我爸可能像哈吉·卡迪尔一样被暗杀。
I mean, there are-- our driver Sotor-- somebody had come, I think, who was sent from the opposition. He started asking our driver questions like, so how many people who are with them at night, sleeping? Me and my dad. Do you guys have any Kaloshnikovs, AKs, guns?
我的意思是，有——我们的司机索托——有人来了，我想，是从反对派那边派来的。他开始问我们的司机问题，比如，那么你们晚上有多少人跟他们在一起，睡觉？我和我爸。你们有卡拉什尼科夫，AK，枪吗？
I don't know. A lot of times, just like driving in the car, the whole scene plays out in my mind. Some guys jumping out and shooting at my dad.
我不知道。很多时候，就像开车一样，整个场景在我脑海里浮现。几个人跳出来向我爸开枪。
Coming up. What happens when your father becomes the official government spokesperson for a country that is barely holding together? Hyder's first person account continues in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将播出。当你的父亲成为一个几乎无法维持统一的国家的政府官方发言人时，会发生什么？海德的第一人称叙述将在来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际的节目继续后的一分钟内继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
If you're just tuning in, today we're devoting our show to the story of a teenager who was raised in Northern California who got a chance to live in the country his parents came from, the country he considers his real home, Afghanistan. Hyder Akbar took a tape recorder to make an audio diary of his time in Kabul. His father had moved back to Afghanistan a few months before him, back when the Taliban fell, to work in the new Afghan government.
如果你刚调过来，今天我们把节目献给一个在北加州长大，有机会生活在他父母来自的国家——他认为是他真正家园的阿富汗的青少年的故事。海德·阿克巴尔带了一台录音机，为他在喀布尔的时光制作了一本音频日记。他的父亲在他之前几个月就搬回了阿富汗，回到了塔利班倒台的时候，为新阿富汗政府工作。
Up until this point in our story, his father was officially the governor of Kunar Province. But then, the day the vice president was assassinated, July 5, Hyder's father got a new job. He became the official spokesman for the entire Afghan government. Hyder became his unofficial assistant.
在我们的故事讲到这里之前，他父亲正式是库纳尔省的省长。但后来，副总统被暗杀的那天，7月5日，海德的父亲得到了一份新工作。他成为了整个阿富汗政府的官方发言人。海德成为了他非正式的助手。
If there had ever been a chance that Hyder would put his father into his audio diaries, that chance kind of vanished with the new job. After the new job, anything his father would say to him about Afghanistan would be essentially the government's official line on it. Imagine Jenna Bush trying to interview her dad about, say, the politics of the Senate, and you can see how delicate the whole thing would be.
如果曾经有机会让海德把他的父亲写进他的音频日记，那种机会随着新工作而消失了。在那份新工作之后，他父亲告诉他的关于阿富汗的一切基本上都是政府的官方口径。想象一下珍娜·布什试图采访她父亲关于，比如说，参议院政治的问题，你就能看出整件事会是多么微妙。
Hyder's diaries continue with his father, Said Fazal Akbar, in his new job as government spokesman.
海德的日记将随着他的父亲，赛义德·法扎尔·阿克巴尔，作为政府发言人的新工作继续进行。
OK. We're heading north to work, to the palace. [SPEAKING PASHTO] It's 9 o'clock. We're going down the stairs, leaving the hotel. OK. We're heading off to the car. People stopping my dad on the way. This is basically how every morning of ours starts.
好了。我们正向北去工作，去宫殿。[说普什图语]现在9点。我们要下楼了，离开酒店。好的。我们正向车走去。人们在路上拦住我爸。这基本上就是我们每天早晨开始的方式。
In the morning, my dad usually just goes to meet up with Karzai and see what's going on, gives me the phone to take messages, et cetera. Stuff like that. That's what I basically do, is help my dad out. The interesting parts are usually when there's something happened, like the President of Iran is coming.
早晨，我爸通常只是去和卡尔扎伊会合，看看发生了什么，给我手机让我帮忙收消息等等。之类的东西。我基本做的就是帮忙。有趣的部分通常是发生什么事的时候，比如伊朗总统要来。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
They started to play the national anthem of Iran and sounded really out of tune.
他们开始演奏伊朗国歌，听起来非常跑调。
[MUSIC - NATIONAL ANTHEM OF IRAN]
[音乐 - 伊朗国歌]
23 years of war. If you think about it-- wow, it's a bad thing. But when you actually go see it, I mean, it really hits you. It's only been like six, seven months, and you can still almost be proud of them, that in that little time, they've achieved this much, at least. And just even seeing that they have the heart to go on with the band makes you proud.
23年的战争。如果你想想看——哇，这是一件坏事。但当你真正去看看它，我的意思是，它真的震撼了你。这不过是六、七个月，你仍然几乎可以为他们感到自豪，在那么短的时间里，他们至少实现了这么多。仅仅看到他们有决心继续组建乐队也让你感到自豪。
Standing outside on the balcony. I see our car parked. My driver's here. Me and my driver are going to go to Jalalabad today.
站在阳台上。我看到我们的车停在那里。我的司机在这。我和我的司机今天要去贾拉拉巴德。
Jalalabad. We started walking through this place.  My driver knows a friend, and we're staying at his house. And we got to talk to him a little bit, and he's an really interesting character. And I can't even begin to tell his story.
贾拉拉巴德。我们开始步行穿过这个地方。我司机认识一个朋友，我们住在他的房子里。我们和他聊了一会儿，他是一个非常有意思的人。我甚至没法开始讲述他的故事。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
He's managed to be arrested in Africa, he's been arrested in Singapore, and he's been arrested in Malaysia. You might ask what he was arrested for. He's been trying to come to America or London. He's trying to get to the West.
他设法在非洲被捕，在新加坡被捕，还在马来西亚被捕。你可能会问他因何被捕。他一直试图来美国或伦敦。他想去西方。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
He was actually in Rwanda before he was going to go to London, and 9/11 happened. And this guy was in jail for four months in Rwanda. You know, he was like, I couldn't speak the language or anything, and they'd call me al-Qaeda, and they'd say bin Laden's name, and that's the only thing we could understand. And whenever, when we heard bin Laden's name, we would be like, no, no, no.
在去伦敦之前他其实在卢旺达，然后9/11发生了。这家伙在卢旺达坐了四个月监狱。你知道，他说，我甚至不会说那种语言，他们就叫我基地组织，他们会说本·拉登的名字，那是我们唯一能听懂的东西。每当，当我们听到本·拉登的名字时，我们就说，不，不，不。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
In Malaysia, he was as close as getting on the plane. The doors were about to close, and they came in after him, and they were asking questions about his passport, et cetera, and they caught him. And he's going to still try to smuggle his way to America.
在马来西亚，他离登机只有一步之遥。舱门就要关上了，他们跟在他后面进来，他们问关于他护照的问题等等，他们抓住了他。而他仍然要尝试偷渡去美国。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
I don't know. I thought sometimes maybe once I come down here, live here for a little bit, a couple months, do my part to see the country and try to help out a little with my dad-- et cetera, I won't feel so guilty about the situation in Afghanistan. But now I don't know if I'll feel more guilty or less guilty when I come back. When I see firsthand what's going on here, knowing that I can get away from it but other people can't.
我不知道。有时候我想也许一旦我下来，在这里住一会，几个月，尽我的一份力来看看这个国家并尝试帮我爸一点忙——等等，我就不会对阿富汗的局势感到那么内疚了。但现在我不知道当我回去时，是会感到更内疚还是更少内疚。当我亲眼目睹这里正在发生的事情时，知道我可以摆脱它，但其他人不能。
I got really sick last night. Think I've thrown up about three times and probably gone to the bathroom about another eight or seven times.
我昨晚病得很重。我想我已经吐了三次，可能又跑了七八次厕所。
There's this kebab. It's called Shami kebab. It's basically made of a kind of ground beef. People tend to stay away from Shami kebab. Like, not even my driver would eat it, you know? And he's totally used to the food here, and he doesn't eat that, and I eat it almost on a nightly basis. Man. I really like it.
有一种烤肉串。叫Shami烤肉串。它基本是用一种碎牛肉做的。人们倾向于远离Shami烤肉串。就像，连我司机都不吃它，你知道吗？而且他完全习惯了这里的食物，他不吃那个，而我几乎每天晚上都吃。天哪。我真的很喜欢它。
And it got me last night. So I was eating it, and then halfway through it, I noticed that one of the kebabs was like-- the inside was just totally red. I was like, oh, well, screw it. I've already ate half of it now.
昨晚它让我中招了。所以我当时正在吃它，吃到一半时，我注意到其中一个烤肉串是——里面完全是红色的。我当时想，噢，好吧，去它的。我已经吃掉一半了。
I think I purposely don't-- I'm not careful, you know? I drink tap water, sink water, unbottled-- I guess it's sort of trying to adapt. Just like I didn't take any vaccination shots, et cetera, before I got here. I think I'm paying the price for it now, too, because I get sick almost every week.
我想我是有意不——我不小心，你知道？我喝自来水，水槽的水，没瓶装的——我想这是一种适应。就像我没有在来这里之前打任何疫苗一样。我想我现在也在为此付出代价，因为我几乎每周都生病。
I have grown up in the States most of my life. And a lot of times, I almost feel like I'm in denial of it. Or I don't want to accept it, that I am a little bit American. Not a little bit. A lot American.
我一生中大部分时间都在美国长大。很多时候，我几乎觉得自己是在否认它。或者我不愿接受，我确实有一点美国人。不是一点。是非常美国人。
Another thing that has to be noted is the-- I don't know. It's just a total lack of the whole female species. I could go like a week without seeing a lady's face. Like, out of a hundred women, like, 95 still wear burkas.
另一件必须注意的事情是——我不知道。它就是女性物种的完全缺失。我可能一周都看不到一张女人的脸。比如，一百个女人里，95个仍然戴着罩袍。
Kabul market is pretty bustling. at home it would be like Times Square. It's full of ladies in burkas that are-- the rest are all men. Like, literally. Here. I'll start counting, and I'll look for a woman's face, and I'll tell you how long it takes. Burka, burka, burka. Man. Burka. Burka. Still no woman.
喀布尔市场相当繁忙。在家里这就像时代广场。到处都是穿罩袍的女士——其余全是男人。真的。这里。我要开始数数，我会找一张女人的脸，我会告诉你需要多久。罩袍，罩袍，罩袍。男人。罩袍。罩袍。还是没有女人。
Since I've been here-- I think it's been like a month and a half or two months-- I don't think I've talked to a girl or to a woman, to a lady, about anything for more than ten seconds. I'm surrounded by men. At home, at the hotel room, in the office. Everywhere we go, it's just men, men, men, men, men. And it's really weird.
自从我来到这里——我想已经有一个半月或两个月了——我不认为我和一个女孩或一个女人，一位女士，谈过超过十秒钟的任何事情。我被男人包围着。在家，在酒店房间，在办公室。无论我们去哪，全是男人，男人，男人，男人，男人。这真的很奇怪。
And it has had an effect on me. You know? Like when women are around you-- I don't know. You're more civilized? They hold you back a little. But you know, here, it's sort of like, how I used to look at violence, or like killing-- it's almost become normal to me now. It's really weird.
它确实对我产生了影响。你知道吗？就像当有女人在你身边时——我不知道。你更文明了？她们会让你收敛一点。但你知道，在这里，它有点像，我过去如何看待暴力，或者像杀人——它现在对我来说几乎变得正常了。这真的很奇怪。
OK. I'm in my room. I mean, not in my room. In the balcony. And it's about 2:30 in the afternoon. And I've got some weapons in front of me. Here's a Makarov pistol-- a brand new pistol. We got this as part of our security.
好了。我在我的房间里。我是说，不是在房间里。在阳台上。大约是下午2:30。我面前有一些武器。这是一把马卡洛夫手枪——一把全新的手枪。我们作为安保的一部分得到了这个。
But next to me is the infamous Kalashnikov.
但在我旁边的是那臭名昭著的卡拉什尼科夫步枪。
[GUN COCKING]
[枪械上膛声]
I just like this noise a lot. [GUN COCKING]
我非常喜欢这个声音。[枪械上膛声]
Let me take this apart. First you take the top off, and then you take this out. The bullets.
让我把它拆开。首先你把上面取下来，然后你把这个拿出来。子弹。
My uncle has a rift with his own family. Like, I think it's, I'm not sure. But it's something like that. His younger brother actually killed Sotor my driver's, first cousin. And they have like no shame, you know? They come to the room-- like, he came in, he greeted us, he shook hands. He shook hands with my driver. The younger brother. This is the younger brother, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Totally normal and nonchalant. And he left the room, and when he left the room, Sotor told me, he's like, you know, that guy killed my first cousin. I was like, what?
我叔叔和他自己的家庭有争执。就像，我想是，我不确定。但类似那样。他的弟弟实际上杀了我的司机索托的堂兄弟。他们简直没脸，你知道吗？他们来到房间——就像，他进来了，他问候了我们，他握了手。他和我的司机握了手。弟弟。这是弟弟，[听不清]。完全正常，冷淡。然后他离开了房间，当他离开房间时，索托告诉我，他就像，你知道，那个家伙杀了我堂兄弟。我当时想，什么？
OK. These are the bullets. I have one bullet in my hand and it-- I'm hitting the mike with it. It's really sharp.
好了。这些是子弹。我手里有一颗子弹，它——我正用它敲麦克风。它真的很锋利。
The first time Sotor when he told me that story about him killing his cousin, and now it's a big deal-- I pretended like it was something normal, you know? Then more stories and more stories now, and somebody tells me, you know, that guy needs to kill them, I'm like, mm, OK. They should probably kill them. I'm not like, hm, killing, bad, or something.
第一次当索托告诉我那个关于他杀了他堂兄弟的故事，现在这成了件大事——我假装这很正常，你知道吗？然后更多的故事，现在有人告诉我，你知道，那个家伙需要杀了他们，我就说，嗯，好吧。他们可能应该杀了他们。我不会像，嗯，杀人，坏，什么的。
Just being in this-- just for a month and a half, being here, and going through so many changes, it's really weird. I can only imagine what it would be like if I lived here for like a year.
仅仅是待在这种环境中——才待了一个半月，在这里，经历如此多的变化，真的很奇怪。我只能想象如果我在这里住一年会是什么样。
I would say it's about 3:30 in the afternoon. We were in our room, and I was listening to U2. Had my head down, trying to go to sleep. And the bed shook, and I heard a loud boom! I came outside real quick, and I noticed all this smoke coming out from behind the Ministry of Communications, which is the building right in front of us. So another bomb explosion in Kabul. Just one of a bunch recently.
我想大概是下午3:30。我们在房间里，我正在听U2。低着头，想去睡觉。床震动了，我听到一声巨响！我很快跑到外面，注意到所有这些烟从通讯部后面冒出来，那是就在我们前面的大楼。所以喀布尔又发生了一起炸弹爆炸。只是最近发生的一连串中的一个。
OK, hello? I just went to find out what the explosion was all about. And apparently it's a lot more serious than I thought. I start heading out and I ran into someone I know, and he said-- he was just coming from there, and he was like, don't go there. You don't want to go there, trust me. You don't want to see it.
喂，喂？我刚去查那次爆炸到底是怎么回事。显然比我想象的严重得多。我开始往外走，碰到了一个我认识的人，他说——他刚从那里过来，他说，别去那。你不想去那，相信我。你不想看到它。
It happened in the middle of a really crowded marketplace. Probably the most crowded place in Kabul at this time. And I just saw some of the ambulances that are come back. I think they already took the first injuries. My driver pointed out to me, he's like, there, look over there. And there was actually blood all over the ambulance, the headlights in the front of the car. You can see the car from here, outside of my building, actually.
它发生在一个非常拥挤的市场中心。可能是喀布尔此时最拥挤的地方。我刚看到一些回来的救护车。我想他们已经接走了第一批伤员。我的司机向我指出来，他说，在那，看那边。实际上救护车上到处都是血，在车前部的车灯上。你可以从这里看到那辆车，实际上在我的大楼外面。
Oh. There's some peacekeepers coming along, and I see some more-- I don't know. I'll probably listen to the news soon.
哦。有一些维和人员过来了，我看到更多——我不知道。我可能很快会听新闻。
Hello? OK. You can hear the BBC in the background. This is reported. And it was pretty quick, actually. It was probably about five minutes later. The BBC just reported, "Breaking News-- Explosion In the Center of Kabul."
喂？好的。你可以在背景中听到BBC。这是报道。实际上很快，大概五分钟后。BBC刚刚报道，“突发新闻——喀布尔中心发生爆炸。”
And they say, the interior minister spokesman actually said, it could be in Kabul Hotel, which is where we're staying. So I know once my mom, if my mom was watching the news right now, she'd be freaking out. But it's not in Kabul Hotel, because we are in Kabul Hotel.
他们说，内政部长发言人实际上说，它可能在喀布尔酒店，也就是我们住的地方。所以我知道一旦我妈，如果我妈现在正在看新闻，她一定会吓坏的。但它不在喀布尔酒店，因为我们就在喀布尔酒店。
Oh, there's more. More peacekeeping troops. But you can hear the chatter in the background and interviews on the TV.
哦，还有。更多的维和部队。但你可以在背景中听到人们的谈话和电视上的采访。
--it's an explosion in central Kabul. Some reports say at least 22 are dead.
——这是喀布尔中心发生的爆炸。一些报道说至少有22人死亡。
So we're here. Right where the wreckage is. I'm standing in front of the wreckage. It's a closed-off area, but my dad got through, saying he's Karzai's spokesman. He needs to check out what's going on.
所以我们在这。就在残骸所在的地方。我站在残骸前面。这是一个封闭区域，但我爸进去了，说他是卡尔扎伊的发言人。他需要看看发生了什么。
Sorry about this.
对此抱歉。
That's a French reporter. He knows my dad. He recognized  him and started talking to him.
那是位法国记者。他认识我爸。他认出了他并开始和他交谈。
I hope it is the first and the last. I hope, really, deep in my--
我希望这是第一次也是最后一次。我希望，真的，深在我心底——
I'm standing in front of the car that blew up. It's completely destroyed. You can hear me hitting the metal.
我站在那辆爆炸的车前面。它完全被摧毁了。你可以听到我敲打金属的声音。
And I think this place should be sealed off better. Everything is evidence, all around me. And it's being tampered with, it's being moved around.
我认为这个地方应该被更好地封锁起来。到处都是证据，在我周围。而且它正在被破坏，被挪动。
In front of me there's a building. It's about four stories high. Glass broken completely, all around. You can hear the glass being piled up.
我面前有一栋大楼。大约四层楼高。玻璃完全碎了，到处都是。你可以听到玻璃被堆起来的声音。
There's all these-- tainted red water. You  can tell they've been trying to wash away the blood. [SPEAKING PASHTO]? OK, we're going to go. I'll get back in the car.
到处都是这些——被污染的红水。你可以看出他们一直在试图洗掉血迹。[说普什图语]？好的，我们要走了。我会回到车里。
OK. I'm at the-- I'll be right back. I'm going to close the door.
好的。我在——我马上回来。我要关门了。
OK. Well, so far there's a bombing earlier in the day. Now my other uncle, who works in the Foreign Ministry, just got a call that there's been an assassination attempt on Karzai. Karzai had gone to Kandahar for his brother's wedding, and my dad was going to go with him too, but he stayed for me. So it's kind of nerve-wracking. Because the guy was actually crying, and saying, if you want to come, go ahead. If you don't-- but you don't know yet.
好的。好吧，目前为止今天早些时候发生了一起爆炸。现在我在外交部工作的另一个叔叔刚接到电话，说发生了针对卡尔扎伊的暗杀企图。卡尔扎伊去了坎大哈参加他兄弟的婚礼，我爸也本打算跟他去，但他为了我留了下来。所以这很令人紧张。因为那个人实际上在哭，说，如果你想去，就去吧。如果你不想——但你还不知道。
I think there's a pretty good chance Karzai has been killed. And if Karzai is gone now, it will be totally the end of it. Because I can't see anybody replacing Karzai.
我认为卡尔扎伊被杀的可能性很大。如果卡尔扎伊现在走了，那将是彻底的终结。因为我想不出有谁能取代卡尔扎伊。
Well, our correspondent, Lyse Doucet, was traveling with President Karzai when that assassination attempt was made. She has this exclusive eyewitness report.
好吧，我们的记者莱斯·杜塞特在发生那次暗杀企图时正和卡尔扎伊总统一起旅行。她有这篇独家目击报道。
The president was back in Kandahar for a family wedding. He waved from his car. Then the man out to kill him made his move. [GUNS SHOOTING] American bodyguards rained rapid fire from the car behind. And hooked their mark. And the president was quickly swept away. Lyse Doucet, BBC News.
总统回到了坎大哈参加一场家庭婚礼。他从车里挥手。然后那个要杀他的人采取了行动。[枪声]美国保镖从后面的车里倾泻出快速火力。并击中了他们的目标。总统被迅速带走。莱斯·杜塞特，BBC新闻。
My dad is talking to my mom on the phone. I just spoke to her too, so.
我爸正在电话里跟我妈谈话。我也刚和她说过话，所以。
[SPEAKING PASHTO]
[说普什图语]
My mom was like, please come home.
我妈说，请回家吧。
I'm getting a lot of calls from these agencies that want a comment out of my dad. And my dad can't, because he just doesn't have enough information about what's going on. And it's very frustrating, because I'm screening the calls. And they just won't take no for an answer.
我收到了很多想从我爸那里得到评论的机构打来的电话。但我爸没法接受，因为他只是没有足够的信息知道正在发生什么。而且非常令人沮丧，因为我在过滤这些电话。他们就是不接受拒绝。
There's like two satellite phones Karzai has. He called both of them. Both of them are off the hook. They're not working. And that's that.
卡尔扎伊有两部卫星电话。他打了两部。两部都打不通。没工作。就这样。
September 5, 2002. A black day for Afghanistan.
2002年9月5日。阿富汗的黑色一天。
Today, it's the day after the assassination. And I'm going downstairs. I'm in front of my dad's office. I just got out of there. Karzai's in a meeting with him, and after that, there will be the press conference. He's holding a press conference. He told my dad to hold a press conference. OK, I'm entering the palace.
今天，是暗杀后的第二天。我正下楼。我在我爸办公室前。我刚从那里出来。卡尔扎伊正在和他开会，之后将会有新闻发布会。他正在举行新闻发布会。他告诉我爸举行新闻发布会。好了，我正在进入宫殿。
OK. That's Lyse Doucet from the BBC. She was actually with the president in Kandahar yesterday, and she's, I think, going to do another report from here.
好的。那是来自BBC的莱斯·杜塞特。她昨天确实和总统在坎大哈，我想她要从这里做另一篇报道。
OK, the gate's open. Here's the president. Huge crowd.
好了，大门开了。那是总统。巨大的人群。
Lyse, I saw your footage this morning.
莱斯，我今天早上看了你的录像。
It's  your footage sir.
那是您的录像，长官。
My footage is your footage.
我的录像就是您的录像。
I'm literally the first person standing here, right next to Karzai. I'm about five feet away from him.
我简直是站在这里的第一人，就在卡尔扎伊旁边。我离他大概五英尺。
They are saying it is extremely dangerous for you to move out of Kabul among your people.
他们说你搬出喀布尔在人民中间活动是非常危险的。
It is always dangerous Lyse. Come on! I've been through this before. I've been hit three times when we were fighting the Soviets. Did that stop us from fighting the Soviets? My father was assasinated in the Kremlin by the Taliban interers. Did that stop him from fighting against  them? I was almost killed in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Did it stop him from fighting?  I will not stop. I will continue. I'm more concerned about the lot of life yesterday in Kabul than of one assassination attempt against me.
总是很危险，莱斯。来吧！我以前经历过这个。我们和苏联人战斗时我被击中过三次。那阻止了我们与苏联人战斗吗？我父亲被塔利班异己在克里姆林宫暗杀。那阻止了他反抗他们吗？我差点在[听不清]被杀。那阻止了他战斗吗？我不会停止。我会继续。我比起针对我的一次暗杀企图，更关心昨天在喀布尔失去的生命。
Every time I hear Karzai speak in an interview or at a press conference, I get hopeful. And I'm like, it's going to happen. He's going to make it. Look at him talk. There's no way he's not going to make it. But then I see what's going on, and then I'm like, OK.
每次我听到卡尔扎伊在采访或新闻发布会上发言时，我都感到充满希望。我就想，这会发生的。他会成功的。看他谈话。他不可能不成功。但然后我看到正在发生的事情，然后我就想，好吧。
I just woke up. I've gotten sick again and I have stomach pain, diarrhea. I just feel out of it. At night, sometimes I sleep outside. There's a bed in the balcony. And I usually have to cover myself in a blanket from head to toe.
我刚醒。我又生病了，肚子疼，腹泻。我感觉不太好。晚上，有时我睡在外面。阳台上有一张床。我通常必须从头到脚用毯子裹住自己。
You can hear the birds chirping in the background. It's almost trying to fool you, in a sense. Birds chirping. It's such a peaceful sound, you know? I don't know. When I hear birds chirping, I get a sense of, you know, rise and shine. Good morning. Sunny day outside. And it's nothing like that.
你可以听到背景中鸟儿在叽叽喳喳地叫。从某种意义上说，它几乎试图欺骗你。鸟儿在叫。这是一种如此和平的声音，你知道吗？我不知道。当我听到鸟叫时，我有一种，你知道，起床上班的感觉。早上好。外面阳光明媚。但这根本不是那回事。
I hate to be like the grumpy pessimist, but pretty sure another bomb's going to go off. It's not stable. I mean, in the last two weeks, there's been over a dozen explosives. A lot of little ones so far. And I know they've been hushed up, and you know, this creates a sense of tension in the air. They're starting to realize, hey. They really don't have control as much as they like to pretend they do.
我讨厌变得像个脾气暴躁的悲观主义者，但我很确定另一枚炸弹要爆炸了。它不稳定。我的意思是，在过去的两周里，发生了十几起爆炸物。到目前为止有很多小炸弹。我知道它们被掩盖了，你知道，这在空气中造成了一种紧张感。他们开始意识到，嘿。他们确实没有像他们假装的那样有控制权。
You know, I was a lot more optimistic and hopeful about the future of Afghanistan before I came. Now it's like, I'll be happy if it doesn't burst into civil war again for five years.
你知道，我来之前对阿富汗的未来乐观且充满希望得多。现在就像，如果它五年内不再陷入内战，我会很高兴的。
Birds chirping. Rise and shine. Stomach's cramping up.
鸟儿在叫。起床上班。胃在绞痛。
I really honestly feel that Afghanistan would not have the problems it's having right now if Abdul Haq was alive. It's almost like, you know, a person walking, and you know, Karzai was one leg, and Abdul Haq could have been the other leg, and one leg's cut off now. Karzai's trying his best to hobble along, but he can't, because one half is missing.
我真的诚实地认为，如果阿卜杜勒·哈克活着，阿富汗就不会有现在的问题。这几乎就像，你知道，一个走路的人，你知道，卡尔扎伊是一条腿，阿卜杜勒·哈克可能是另一条腿，现在一条腿被砍掉了。卡尔扎伊正尽力蹒跚前行，但他不能，因为少了一半。
He's definitely somebody I look up to, somebody I'd like to follow. I mean, he did the Kalema, which is, you know, professing your faith. You know "There's no God but Allah and Muhammad is the messenger of Allah." And you know that when you're a newborn and a person whispers that in your ear to sort of make you officially Muslim. It's almost like, you know, how Catholics get baptized.
他绝对是我敬仰的人，我想追随的人。我是说，他念了Kalema，也就是，你知道，表白你的信仰。你知道“万物非主，唯有真主，穆罕默德是真主的使者”。你知道当你是个新生儿时，有人在你耳边低语那句话是为了让你正式成为穆斯林。这几乎像，你知道，天主教徒如何受洗。
My dad, my family, picked Abdul Haq to do it. He was chuckling while he was doing it in my ear, too, because he couldn't believe it, that they were asking him to do it. Because usually you ask an older person to do it. Like almost a religious elder to do it. But they wanted Abdul Haq to do it, because they're like, we want him to follow in your footsteps. So even from the beginning, I've always sort of looked up to him.
我爸，我的家人，选了阿卜杜勒·哈克来做这件事。他在我耳边念的时候也在轻笑，因为他简直不敢相信，他们竟然让他来做这件事。因为通常你会请一个更年长的人来做。就像几乎请一个宗教长者来做。但他们想让阿卜杜勒·哈克来做，因为他们说，我们想让他追随你的脚步。所以从一开始，我就一直敬仰他。
I told my dad the last thing I wanted to do before I left Afghanistan was to visit Abdul Haq's grave.
我告诉我爸我离开阿富汗前想做的最后一件事是去拜访阿卜杜勒·哈克的坟墓。
OK. I'm going up the road to Abdul Haq's grave. OK. Road ends here. Now we're walking. Me and my driver. We're going to walk the rest of the way. Do you hear a little low wind blowing? I'm covered in dust. It was a terrible journey getting here. We're walking around, trying to find it.
好的。我正沿着路去阿卜杜勒·哈克的坟墓。好的。路在这结束。现在我们要步行。我和我的司机。我们要步行走完剩下的路。你听到风在低声吹吗？我浑身是灰。去那里的旅程太可怕了。我们在四处走，试图找到它。
No, it's not here. Why don't we ask somebody. Here we go. We found some guy walking. OK. It is the graveyard. OK. Here we are.
不，它不在这里。为什么我们不问问人。这儿呢。我们发现了一个人正在走。好的。这是墓地。好的。我们到了。
I'm sitting here next to a bunch of rocks piled up. And there's not even a board or anything that says Abdul Haq. I mean, we walked right past it a second ago, and I was like-- me and my driver were both like, no, this is not it, and we kept going forward.
我正坐在这一堆岩石旁边。甚至没有一块木板或其他什么东西写着阿卜杜勒·哈克。我的意思是，我们刚才走过了它，我当时想——我和我的司机都说，不，这不是它，我们就继续向前走。
It's a quiet place. You don't hear much. It's the middle of nowhere. Mountains all around me. I'm sitting down on the gravel. I'm sitting down on the dirt.
这是一个安静的地方。你听不到什么。它在荒郊野外。周围都是山。我坐在碎石上。我坐在泥土上。
I can't believe I'm sitting down next to his body. I don't know how to explain it. Just like the whole legend behind him-- jihad hero, and freedom fighter, and visiting Reagan and Margaret Thatcher, and all the media that was around him.
我不敢相信我正坐在他的尸体旁边。我不知道该怎么解释。就像他背后的整个传奇——圣战英雄，自由战士，访问里根和玛格丽特·撒切尔，还有围绕他的所有媒体。
And now he's in like this little [BLEEP] cemetery. Not even a sign that [BLEEP] says "Abdul Haq."
而现在他在这个[被消音]小墓地里。甚至连一个[被消音]写着“阿卜杜勒·哈克”的牌子都没有。
Hello, hello? OK. Today's September 11, 2002. It's actually my last night in Peshawar. I'm at a relative's house. I'm spending the night here. And you can hear the food cooking here in the kitchen.
喂，喂？好的。今天是2002年9月11日。实际上是我在白沙瓦的最后一晚。我在一个亲戚家。我今晚住在这。你可以听到厨房里做饭的声音。
I'm really excited about coming home. Anyway, I'm going to, I should probably go to the other rooms. I think some September 11 anniversary is going on.
我真的对回家感到兴奋。总之，我要，我应该去别的房间。我想9月11日的周年纪念正在进行。
[MUSIC - "THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER"]
[音乐 - 《星条旗》]
I think it's kind of ironic that I am coming back on the the day of September 11.
我认为我在9月11日这天回来有点讽刺。
Here's Afghanistan.
这里是阿富汗。
In a statement read at the ceremony, Afghan president Hamid Karzai said the al-Qaeda terrorists behind the September 11 attacks had also wreaked havoc on his country.
在仪式上宣读的一份声明中，阿富汗总统哈米德·卡尔扎伊表示，9/11袭击背后的基地组织恐怖分子也给他的国家造成了严重破坏。
At times, I almost wish I hadn't come. It was almost better when I was away from it all, and it was still I looked up to it. Now I think about it, and I'm like, why? Why bother with them here? Maybe I should just go back to the States. Study Business. Start working with my brother. Be a loan officer. Go and open up my brokerage. Live a comfortable life.
有时候，我几乎希望我没来过。当我远离这一切时，它几乎更好，我还敬仰它。现在我想想它，我就想，为什么？为什么要在他们这里费心呢？也许我应该回美国。学商科。开始和我哥哥一起工作。当贷款员。去开设我的经纪行。过舒适的生活。
I don't think I could live comfortably like that. Now I'll just be thinking about what's going on in Afghanistan and what I could do to help.
我不认为我能那样舒适地生活。现在我会一直在想阿富汗正在发生什么，我能做些什么来帮忙。
Hyder Akbar is now a freshman at Diablo Valley college in California. He's planning on returning to Afghanistan with his next school break.
海德·阿克巴尔现在是加州迪亚布罗谷学院的大一新生。他正计划在下一个学假带着他的书回到阿富汗。
Susan Burton is the one who gave him a tape recorder and produced this story for our program. Funding for her radio stories comes from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
苏珊·伯顿是那个给他录音机并为我们节目制作这个故事的人。她的广播故事的资助来自公共广播公司。
It's my equivalent, I think, of Lollapalooza or something. Going backstage and getting to meet all of these, like, rock stars.
我想这是我的洛拉帕罗扎音乐节之类的地方。走到后台，见到所有这些，像，摇滚明星。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。